maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
tout va bien
le chômage diminue le pays tient un cap
charisma croissance à tous les étages
bref cette semaine dont j'aurais parlé
les patrimoines ont été publiés moi je
me suis précipitée j'ai allumé le redis
cliquer sur la page baisser mon froc
attrapé mon sopalin
consternation consternation je cherchais
l'oeil ou pan du patrimoine je suis
tombé sur leboncoin.fr tu vois à côté
louis la brocante c'est un magasin
hermès comme c'est un truc
bon il ya des motifs de soulagement j'ai
plus de blake benoît hamon
benoît hamon tout le monde voit la
fashion victim qui se tirent la bourre
vestimentaire avec manuel valls hamon tu
le croises avec un sac tati tu lui dis
alors beau gosse c'est la gloire
à mon nom mais je le plains quoi le mec
il a une opel corsa à 4600 euros quoi
doit pas être évident pour emballer à la
sortie de chez castel
évidemment aucun ministre n'a un compte
en suisse tu m'étonnes quoi vu les
sommes qu'ils annoncent à part fabius et
delaunay quand tu es banques et en
suisse t'as pas envie d'avoir des
clients qui gagnent moins que tu as
secrétaire
inutile de dire qu'il n'y en a pas un
qui possède des actions en
investissement dans une boîte mais ça
c'est l'ennemie de la finance tout chaud
le vieux logiciel socialiste comme ça
c'est leur la us quoi faut plus de
crèches d'écoles et d'hôpitaux c'est
vraiment génial très que des endroits
qui te rappelles qui n'est pas autonome
c'est un peu le truc c'est en gros s'il
ya 40 ans on n'a pas une rolex et que tu
es peut-être membres du gouvernement
alors j'ai trouvé des incohérences dans
les déclarations j'ai regardé son
attention g geneviève fioraso qui
déclarent une twingo à 8000 euros sans
déconner ça existe twingo à 8000 euros
franchement à moins d'avoir 20 grammes
de coke dans la boîte à gants je vois
pas trop comment c'est possible
[Applaudissements]
elle n'est pas la seule à avoir des
trucs un peu il ya belkacem qui a un
scooter d'une valeur de 500 euros elle a
acheté à la sortie du métro de barbès
qui tu sais le truc ticket marlborough
piaggio
après vingt ans de politique je crois
que vous en avait parlé aussi moscovici
possède un patrimoine de 3000 euros de
plus que cécile duflot non mais s'il
duflot 1 et le pire c'est qu'il a deux
fois moins de pognon que le ministre de
la culture le ministre de l'économie
moins riche que le ministre de la
culture générale c'est comme si serge
dassault gagner moins que le premier
secrétaire la cgt
moi je comprends cahuzac et quitter le
gouvernement avant la publication parce
que pas mêlé son patrimoine à celui des
autres et en termes de glamour cahuzac
au milieu de ce gouvernement c'est comme
garer une bentley sur le parking de la
halle à chaud sur
le port le post c'est à dire en plus il
et il a dû se taper cette confession à
la télé le mec tout contrit penaud c'est
comme s'il avait filé les plans de la
ligne maginot à merkel
est rompue en profite pour faire sa
sortie du moment il a dit qu'il a trouvé
l'interview pathétique
jean-marc quand on est premier ministre
de la cinquième puissance mondiale et
qu'on déclare un combi volkswagen à 1000
euros
on a la décence de la fermer
[Applaudissements]
il a rajouté quelque chose avant de
servir eu ma part d'ombré c'est mon
combi volkswagen
avant sous la banquette arrière il ya qu
à xavier dupont de ligonnès
ou là alors évidemment la question que
peut faire hollande à l'elysée que peut
faire rené coty que peu notre bien aimée
je sais pas moi condamné les fenêtres
construire des murs prière faire
bouillir de l'huile
commander une perruque à cahuzac se
foutent des implants mammaires préparer
la fuite quatuor au rythme où ça va
c'est pas bernard arnault qu'on va
choper à la frontière belge ces hollande
économie
petroplus ferme on ne raffinera plus de
pétrole en normandie en même temps
est-ce qu'on affine des camemberts au
qatar
sport
deux explosions à l'arrivée du marathon
de boston je comprends moi je comprends
moi les gens qui mettent plus de quatre
heures un marathon ça me saoule
non mais le vrai problème avec tout ça
non mais un problème c'est un problème
de fond pour réfléchir pour s'engager
dire on sait pas qui a gagné la course
enfin si c'est al-qaïda je veux dire
passé de 3000 morts le 11 septembre 2001
à trois morts douze ans plus tard c'est
à croire que al qaida intégrer la zone
euro
nécrologie
margaret thatcher a été enterré alors ça
a coûté 12 millions d'euros alors
attention à la famille a payé la
crémation les fleurs le transport en
fait les 12 millions c'est les mesures
de sécurité
la sécurité
elle est morte
préparer un attentat sur une personne
décédée c'est un concept
journalisme justin bieber a visité la
maison d'anne frank jusque là pourquoi
pas et dans le livre d'or il a écrit
anne était une fille formidable elle
aurait sans doute été fan de moi c'est
dur à dire enfin en revanche si la
vecquerie ça dans le livre d'or de la
maison marc dutroux
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est super
ça mais c'est pour ça qu'on paye
mariage alors l'ump déclare que si elle
arrive au pouvoir elle ne va pas abroger
la loi sur le mariage mais la modifier
c'est comme les 35 heures ça c'est vous
reprochez à hollande de faire du sarkozy
au pouvoir alors que vous faites du
holland dans l'opposition
franchement à l'ump je n'ai pas réfléchi
le jour vous arriverez à [ __ ] autant
personnes dans la rue pour manifester
contre la dépense publique que vous
arrivez en mettre pour protester contre
la possibilité d'offrir un cadre légal à
une sodomie on vous prendra peut-être au
sérieux
tourisme le roi de l'évasion redoine
faïd s'est fait la belle ils étaient
enfermés à lille on comprend ça décuple
la motivation va tu as envie de on
l'aurait enfermée à fort de france il
serait encore
lors il avait un flingue des explosifs
il a tenu en joue quatre mathon avant de
prendre la fuite en france s'échapper
d'une prison c'est plus simple que de
rentrer en boîte
justice ouverture du procès de jean
claude mas les droits des prothèses
mammaires frauduleuse par 300 à 400
femmes sont venues assister au procès
quoi dès qu'il s'agit de coquetterie
quoi c'est pas au procès de klaus barbie
qu'on aurait vu une telle concentration
malade alors elles sont là à chouiner or
il est indifférent il s'en fout bout le
méchant il faut qu'il fasse quoi qu'il
arrive rigolard salue les prothèses qui
fuit bip
bien sûr je suis coupable j'ai vu du
mazout mais au prix du brut que j'allais
pas maître du kérosène
bonne nouvelle oui on a découvert un
autoportrait de baudelaire
ah non non ça c'est pas bien ça c'est
autre chose et autres alors on précise
que les clichés n'ont pas été retouchées
ouais c'est dur même photoshop voulait
pas d'elle alors belles années et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux